[Music]
nice to finally meet you Kevin Who Am
IA Kevin Kevin Molly hi I didn't come
over here honestly expecting a date but
you know I feel like that's where this
is going
and there was a righteous man and his
name was job and one day God to decided
that he was going to take away his
protection there
no on Earth
I can we weather a storm together
Kevin
maybe nice to finally meet you
[Music]
Kevin who am I I'm called many names who
am I
really
chaos imagine having the power to move
move people from One reality to the next
to shift them where's my wife I shifted
her Heavenly Father are you
praying we'll answer
first Bells more loud and deep God is
not dead nor
done these Pages they're giving hope
back to south end this search for signs
glimmers in the
darkness that's is him and he's turning
his face towards me the wrong shall fail
the right Prevail with peace all the he
puts his people to the test you've been
here for 5 years how much more patience
you
got God is
here everything that you've put me
through just makes seem that much easier
to
[Music]
see